yah hello welcome to this video on
playing Krupa I am crew / Charlie cop ok
so I'm going to see far probably going
for some kind of Queens gambit yes yeah
do I go for the exchange I think I'll do
that recently this has become a bit more
popular for black to allow this as these
some idea that night h5 have caught some
momentum not right here I'm free but
after night BTW 7 yes so what is this i
can go here night age 5 nope is not
doing that ok I have Knight f3 or 92 and
going for 92 this game and it's also
believed to be pretty good for white
this kind of this kind of setup I mean
pretty good just means yeah maybe good
for some slight edge but not not a huge
advantage ok black is going for c5 I
guess I think I go King edge one getting
out of this now the dead of the diagonal
some potential problems there if you go
see 5 interesting i might just take
actually and then go Knight d4 ok this
is an entirely different matter yeah and
I'm going for
okay I've got a good center but like
probably will get some counter play on
my pawns okay I'm really expected to
take but I think making this pre move as
always a little bit irritating for the
viewer so and sometimes don't enter them
huh that's interesting but I don't
really understand where the nights are
going so I'm going e5 I mean you cannot
go an idea for anyway this just drops
each cell and nights are standing in the
way of f4 f5 so I'm a bit mystified
about black splenium what does he have
some kind of direct some peace play
tweenage for don't believe it so he just
gives away the porn and j/o seems that
he did this on purpose okay so I think
maybe bishop hmm not quite clear where I
want you go now let's go Becky I'm the
sugar fight also is some certainly
possible okay let's kick this away
so his Bishop book come to f5 this is
basically what he's playing for him hmm
I mean I can I can really just dumb yeah
let's do that like f4 and h4 just keep
everything there's nothing particularly
wrong with that now yeah well Bishop f5
is problematic let's go on a dark square
sorry you might play what age 3 huh hmm
hmm maybe I should've played age for
after all yeah it's a bit annoying there
this this thing
so how do I proceed here knight to e
three maybe and down then f5 not f2 is
also a possibility hmm now I didn't play
that too 22 well it's got some decent
decent count to play here
i I really don't think it is objectively
enough but makes things a bit awkward
okay so let's see can you go yeah can I
do something else and capturing and
probably not but it's not not bad so f5
now maybe not quite sure
okay no 23 can take take edge to that I
really have to avoid okay so how do I do
this then hmm interesting look F to the
screen be one and so okay let's make a
small improvement move and see what
happens so how do i get to exchange
Queens here look you want look II 223 or
something no that's not working
look II to rookie to Quincy three Quincy
to this is the way to do it i think now
i really shouldn't have gotten into the
somewhat passive position not really
well played
yeah one question is this you
threatening some kind of I don't know
it's just prevented group which is free
some kind of Perpetual try check Queenie
five it's going to be very annoying
check check mmm going for a rookie five
that should be enough black resign it's
going to lose on time position is not
well maybe it's not so easy forget the
rookie but I can actually double this is
this is the more problematic thing okay
so we got them Queens gambit exchange
this is all kind of normal yeah here I
expected him to take and play something
like this try to use the rooks iam
there's nothing wyd is probably a little
bit better after this but that's what I
expected and now it gets somewhat tricky
f4 f5 hmm he went with this this smooth
hmm ok I actually made a mistake here g4
as much stronger that wins outright and
trapping the night I didn't really think
about it because I was just thinking
okay let me take the bone and that
always good but mm-hmm interesting and
it seems that this is maybe also not the
most precise
Bishop f5 is probably better yeah and
here maybe I really should go for this
kind of business directly preventing any
root age three things I was a bit
reluctant because i was thinking okay
maybe there's some kind of chat thing
happening here immediately but always
have to catch one is nothing happening
and here realize that he's going to
block me on age three and this is not
and that that easy yeah i managed to get
this traded which was I think some
progress yeah I think this is a good
plan getting the Queen over a queen bee
three was the temple maybe but anyway I
thinking here i'm starting to get
control over things again okay the
computer your screen b3f just winning
the pawn their own b7 that's not bad
yeah okay and saw that this is probably
going to win so i went for it ok that
was i think quite ok thanks for watching